[Music]  so why do I hate it who are you here  I want to chase adventures hello is this  guy the cuckoo  what's it like I'm not their own life  you're either sleep deprived or seasick  and after a few days there's that loosen  Asians why do you do it it's a feeling I  can't describe it's just you and the  infinite horizon  how would you like to sail the his  Haneda California verse what do you  think I think for a thousand miles is  insane not going anywhere without you  come sail with me  [Music]  [Music]  thousands of miles from land bring on  any flight paths that's like a 1500  square miles of ichkeria needle in a  haystack  [Music]  my ribs burnin I'll accept it I'm dead  weight Hawaii  mm my shot at a moving target if you  miss Hawaii that's why we died I can't  do this you could do anything you put  your mind to  so halfway around the globe to find you  I'm not a Newcomb  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you